as Russell Reva you got buried what
about that guy's good
Hey there you go limitless we are here
outside of the famous guest room records
we're in Oklahoma City for one of my
favorite days of the year
Record Store Day our love of music at
dock fish runs just as deep as our love
for beer and today's an extra special
day for me because we did a beautiful
collaboration with one of my favorite
bands in history The Flaming Lips
today's episode is all about a couple of
my favorite things music beer
independence and collaboration this is
gonna be fun The Flaming Lips are one of
the most innovative and collaborative
rock bands of all time with more than 30
years of experience in music and iconic
status in Oklahoma City it was a dream
to be able to visit them on their home
turf to bring together fans of indie
music and indie beer through one super
unique collaboration and while I was in
town it was my goal to steal lead singer
Wayne Coyne away from the throngs of
fans and sit down at the beautiful 21c
Hotel to pick his brain about the
creative process and get his reactions
to a few different collaborative brews
the first part of our journey is this
beautiful West Side drank from our
friends at Anthem in stone club this is
a cool story about weaving together
independent Brewers that by nature you'd
say oh well the independent thing must
means that they're always just on their
own doing their own thing but this is a
case of two breweries here in Oklahoma
City who instead of getting pissed off
the first Brewer
when another brewery was over I yeah
yeah they helped each other you know
borrowing grain borrowing equipment and
when the second Brewer finally opened
stone cloud the first Brewer anthem
reached out and said hey let's do
collaboration to try and get more people
to come to this part of the city so take
a sip it's a Brett
pehle all now brett is basically a
special yeast that will give it sort of
a clovie dry character see I like it how
your your you're able to describe what's
in it you get the clothes you get a
little clove ething going on that would
be too advanced yeah for for my palate
at the moment see this is a good beer
beautiful right yeah that's a good bear
I mean I wouldn't be able to describe it
in detail like you are but goods an
adjective all brewers want to hear and
they're asked what do you think of my
beers it's good that's that's great to
hear you guys have chosen to stay in
Oklahoma City how has that informed your
journey in in in the band right how
bigger that is a part of the Flaming
Lips for us we would always serve our
music is made in our mind it's not
really made in an area but in time I
think this story of you know Santa Claus
comes from the North Pole mm-hmm oh cool
yeah you know the Beatles come from
Liverpool The Flaming Lips come from
Oklahoma and that little thing very
first times we ever played somewhere
you'd read the two lines that they'd
write about you in the local paper and
it said say The Flaming Lips making this
music and they come from Oklahoma in the
same way that Flaming Lips are proudly
synonymous with Oklahoma you guys are
all so synonymous with collaboration and
that's the next phase of our literature
that we're gonna Tod collaboration
excellent so this is collaboration not
litigation from Avery brewery and
Russian River brewery the craft brewing
industry is 99% [ __ ] free and these
two are helping us keep our odds
together there's a great story that kind
of personified that where unbeknownst to
either of them they both decided in the
like 2005 to name a beer salvation and
instead of like lawyering up and getting
the yeah trademark wars they said how
about we do our each to salvation and
let's do a blend of our salvations and
call the beer collaboration not litigate
Wow it really is that idea of its dead
about like you're not my enemy if you're
you know if you're doing what I'm doing
and you might do it better than me then
you're my enemy and I should I should
destroy you I think when creative people
are around other creative people they
love it always sort of says it's like
having our superpower you're helping me
you're giving me energy you're giving me
ideas you're making me rethink the
things that I had doubts about yeah and
that's really the truth we always say
that we're more focused on the good
karma that comes with focusing on
collaboration than the negative energy
that comes with focusing on competition
you know see that you said that good
yeah
try the goodness okay he's two breweries
so like I said this one's gonna be a
little stronger
yeah LG warned me yeah Belgian dark ale
that's fermented warm with a Belgian
yeast that will throw esters like fruity
peachy caramel e matter I love that see
I think now you've you've given that to
me before I taste it well maybe maybe
I'm off let's see yeah I mean that's
that's definitely got a good vibe to it
you liking it but if you drink too much
this you're gonna get drunk pretty quick
you gotta pace yourself follow do you
ever coin anyway I loved what you said
about the superpowers and I always think
of it and then raise my children to say
you know everyone has their own unique
superpowers and everyone with every
decision they make can either use those
powers for good or for evil and you know
creatively finding like-minded people
like you said if someone's doing
something similar but in their own way
and they've got their own superpowers
you're like how can we fight evil
together by making something like her
superpowers me using mine can you give
an example of one that blew your mind
the last 30 years of how in sync you and
that collaborative partner were me I
mean I mean Miley is I mean she's like
that as well
you know you think she's Miley Cyrus and
she's a great singer and she's a
flamboyant freak or whatever and people
are still insecure you know the idea
like I don't really know if what I'm
doing is gonna work or if it's any good
and people that allow that you to see
that we all have that anyway I don't
know it's so you said you're invested in
it but it's not just invested like I
want it to succeed you're emotionally in
it and these are these people they're
not they become within your friends as
people that you love so we'll go from
the collaborations of other fine folks
that put their hearts on their sleeves
and trusted each other to the one we got
to do together excellently all right do
this music has always been one of my
biggest inspirations at dogfish so it's
always been a dream of mine that my beer
would inspire musicians as well for this
to a collab I teamed up with indie rock
legends The Flaming Lips to create
dragons and yum-yum's
a tropical pale ale packed with dragon
fruit young berry passion fruit and
black carrot juice lead singer Wayne
Coyne then wrote lyrics inspired by the
broom for a special release called the
story of yum-yum and Dragon pressed into
super limited vinyl records injected
with the beer itself there's music in
the beers and beer the music literally
look at the colour of that one it's an
amazing beautiful color but the most
like important in terms of how it turned
out ingredients dammit that's good right
so the dragon fruit the young berries
the black carrot juice those are
probably the most important ingredients
in terms of how it turned out and they
add fruitiness but it's like an
astringent dry not sweet I see you know
so you're saying astringent this is like
the sour this is the sour part of it
that were yeah like a tart thing yeah
coming from the fruit we jumped on the
phone a little over a year ago and I
said these are some ingredients that
were already thinking about brewing and
then I sent you a package and then you
kind of took it from there with the
musical part of the journey right well
you know like you mentioning the
ingredients and you know the idea that
maybe those could be worked into
something and so I just turned you know
some of the ingredients into these
characters and then you start having
this story and I think I drew this at
the kitchen table and I even this idea
that he's got an ear and he's got three
noses or whatever you know
well that's part of this story
[Music]
stern
so yeah and and you're in you were
encouraging when you know when I showed
you these characters and I think it was
just another one of those Oh Matt this
is this is becoming something our first
conversation where I threw out some
ingredient ideas and you didn't say that
was stupid I kind of like where this is
going
the next sentence out of your mouth was
well if we do a vinyl for Record Store
Day put beer in the vinyl yes and I was
like yes we'll see I'm coming at it from
well I don't know how it could happen
but I know it could happen for sure cuz
we've done wasn't a seven inch but it
was a bigger record filled with human
blood and the blood that was in it was
the back true people that are on the
record Jim James I've got Chris Martin
from Coldplay I've got Kesha's blood
actually their blood it's two normal
pieces of vinyl and then there's this
little thing that's carved out in the
little kid yeah and the way that we put
the blood into our record I had a big
hogs blood blood literally fill it full
I would stick it in the little hole yeah
and then we had this little rubber
cement that would just fill it out and
you have video of you combining Kesha's
blood with James Bligh yeah did Sparks
and smoke start coming out of this of
course it did yeah we've put a lot of
our blood sweat tears our hard work
totally yeah into what we make so and it
is I mean it is a strange thing to see I
mean you think these days all the things
that can be made and it's still it's all
a fascinating thing to see super cool
look good behind the be area that line
them up right craftsmanship is the
process not the product and I have
enjoyed this process with you immensely
Cheers
when it comes to collaborators I've
rarely met someone as enthusiastic and
creatively invested as Wayne Coyne
touring Oklahoma City with its
unofficial mayor and most recognized
rock star was pretty epic and as a music
nerd trapped inside a Brewers body it
was exciting and a little nerve-wracking
to see Flaming Lips fans try this
vibrant tasty beer we made together as
fun as the process is a collaboration
can't realize its full potential until
it's living out the world making people
say that's odd let's drink
[Music]